third well some list of questions to
kick off this uh
discussion the way that i look at
the lineup you mostly have a bunch of
theorists on the call
except maybe for peter so but i'm gonna
be like mostly
directing my yeah i'm gonna also like
put on my learning theorist hat as well
just showing out this
cold water button instead of the norix
swag that everybody's uh
so proud about so yeah from
from the theories perspective what i see
is that uh there are so many
new algorithms that are being introduced
in these past couple years and everybody
has their own favorite words and
terminology to talk
about them and this is
this is i think sort of giving theories
a bit of a bad
name right so if you just read all these
papers and if you just talk about
these kind of exponential weights uh
policies that
well we have we have heard havana call
it politex or aapi before
machi was calling it regularized policy
iteration
yesterday alec was calling it a natural
policy gradients
so uh it seems like a little confusing
you know
and it's a little difficult to approach
this kind of literature if these things
uh
keep happening so i just really wonder
like well
who's responsible for this what can we
do about this how can we better
communicate these results
because eventually we want people to
read these papers and understand them
and
you know take away the big messages from
them
uh none none really seemed to like this
question but
it's kind of a tricky question because
like all these things are
like they're very similar but they're
all like slightly different
and so like with the different names we
just like sort of denote like the subtle
differences
yeah there's also mdpo and there's yeah
all these things i don't know what the
solution is
also the same deal yeah yeah
yeah and i think it's not uh specific to
when you look at the
online optimization uh literature the
you have many algorithms that are known
on under different name
if you look mirror decent ftrm uh
multiplicative weight updates these
names are not from
learning they a different field and
we took a name so the over female
responsible
[Music]
yeah so what i'm dreaming about is
something that has happened in the
online learning
literature in the past decade or so
before
everything was a complete mess and there
were like a bunch of different
algorithms floating around and there was
like no
unified terminology but then everybody
conversely just call and get mirror
descent and
follow the regulized leader so do you
think that this is ever going to happen
in
reinforcement learning and particularly
in theory
well so at least we had only one online
learning problem right everybody agreed
that we have an objective which is
regret first of all so
so for every everything you have uh the
discounted version and the finite
horizon version and the
uh average reward version and uh they
they all have their certain differences
so we can't you know
like i mean i was saying they they all
result in
slight changes to the what the
algorithms have to do and
uh so i i don't know if it's you know
as clean necessarily um
you know in a way you know i i the
reason i kind of
like making um i that's why
we decided to in some sense adopt the
npg-like terminology because
it was kind of maybe going to the
earliest
algorithm with that structure that that
we could
land on so kind of going to maybe the
older terminology in that sense but
um you know i think uh in other cases
there are really
like okay then you know matthew's
playing around with other regularizers
it wouldn't be
fair to put it within the same
nomenclature anymore right so yes you
know it could be that of course you know
uh when we get a broader kind of
unification
of many of these really in a way that
um everything becomes a special case of
something we
can we can we can maybe unify better
um right yeah so
i guess like another thing that uh that
bothers me a little bit on this front is
like what is the definition of policy
gradient algorithms
in the first place because right now if
you read
in particular deep rl papers somebody
says that they did
the policy gradient algorithm usually
for me a policy grade
means that you're using the policy
gradients to estimate the gradients
of the average word objective but
apparently for a lot of people it just
means that you're just taking the
gradient of some policy parameterization
at some point in your algorithm
so just i just really wonder like uh
what's a remedy
uh how can we speak up what is the right
forum to make noise about this
what can we do about this as theorists
this is such a hard question greg i
wonder i wonder if um
you know someone needs to write a theory
book that that puts together all this
nice terminology and makes this nice and
clear
hint gergei maybe you'd like to do
something like that i think it's
probably true that when rich wrote the
textbook that it really helped make the
field have a unified terminology
it's hard for any single paper i think
to cause a unified terminology
i agree with your point about policy
grading that term is just really super
unclear
right yeah maybe secretly i'm looking
for co-authors of this book right now
but actually maybe maybe the way you're
seeing it because you're contrasting
with online learning
i don't feel like rl is that terrible
for terminology or maybe that's not
holding things back too much nor do i
think theorists have a bad name because
of it
at least i've never heard anyone say
anything oh well i guess another thing
is like actor critic algorithms what
does that
really mean in the same way q learning
what does that really mean
is it like the stochastic approximation
algorithm or dfq learning deq and the dq
algorithm doesn't even have a name
that is another
bit of source of a confusion but i guess
from the
from from from the other perspective
uh the question would be that so if uh
somebody is coming from the from the
practical side and they want to get like
a better theoretical understanding of
their algorithm
like from the theoretical perspective
what can we suggest to them
uh like how should they phrase their
questions
and how can we like direct their
attention to like hey this is actually
the part of your algorithm that somehow
should be amenable to theoretical
analysis
how can you reach up to this point
well i guess for for me uh so i didn't
ask this question uh
during peter's talk but maybe i can ask
it right now
is uh uh in your weighted dominar
definition peter you had these weights
and you had this definition you had this
kind of heuristic
for for uh for waiting
there well my question would have been
okay
so how do you picture you know just go
back to the tabular case
and in that setting what would be the
ideal weights what would those
look like in the first place so if you
can answer this question or at least
this is how i think as a theorist
then you can branch out from there and
start to understand
your your algorithm in more general
terms
yeah i like that suggestion i think
going back to tabular would make it a
lot easier to
work out what might be optimal there i
mean
easier i don't know it would be easy in
the absolute but
definitely easier um yeah top of my head
i'm not sure what it would look like but
i like that kind of question yeah
what would it look like in a tablet
is this usually part of your workflow or
when uh
when you come up with algorithms you you
start from a different
perspective just look at the loss
function and try to like figure out how
to adjust this
in a way that is aminable to just great
in this case the way
this came about is essentially we
it it just seemed like you know using
the min or swapping the max
and the arc max seemed just that it was
losing a lot of signal
that that was really the starting point
and then
let's see what else we can do well
ideally we'd have a some kind of
bayesian style loss function that
weights
every piece of information by how much
you can trust it and then things should
work
and then we went to waiting by one over
the variance
you know with the gaussian assumption in
the loss
right um but that that just didn't
really work
and i think yeah i think a reasonable
step could have been to go to what's the
simplest case where we can actually work
it out
uh and see what it yields us instead we
said hey
this doesn't work it seems kind of
unstable what can we do to
you know keep keep this more bounded and
sigmoid will keep it
nicely bounded and it just worked yeah
and then we ran
with it so i understand the specifics
here but uh
i guess my more general question here is
that
well how far do you think that this
approach can be pushed of just
you know experiencing some problem with
your experiments right you just see
something pop up
and then just go back to your loss
function and try to adjust this
do you think that everything can be
solved with this pipeline in
reinforcement learning
because this is a bit of a provocative
question
yeah it's a i mean
that that i mean definitely not in the
sense that they completely ignored
exploration which growl needs to be
solved in a very different
way than just adjusting a loss function
um or it's it's a very complicated loss
function maybe
um yeah all right then i suppose
if i can jump in on this because i think
i want to also answer that question
um uh let me let me take this
into maybe controversial territory
gerger as well i think
uh you know if you do d-parallel on the
practical side
there's actually a lot of issues that
aren't being looked at
from from the theory side at all right
uh
we talked earlier about the fact that um
you know a gradient
step has a cost and it has a very sort
of practical cost that when you
implement your algorithm you have to
think about
that that gradient step um and so i
wonder if in this context it's also
sort of reflective of of that
that uh and this is maybe my challenge
here is you know is is
is the theory addressing the practical
questions or are there lots of questions
that we should be thinking about that
just
aren't being surfaced right now uh i i
don't know peter if you would agree with
me on this that
there's this extra layer of stuff that
doesn't get theorized at all
if that makes sense yeah so i think
i think maybe one one extra layer here
is just a sociological layer which is
different students different postdocs
have very different
flavors of things that they like to work
on right and i think that often has a
lot more influence on exactly how the
path goes than
maybe what is you know maybe the
rational most rational
you know um but so
to mark's point i think often there are
things where at a high level intuition
goes
unused and then you can put together an
algorithm that intuitively makes sense
and works pretty well
like what we did in this case and yet
lends itself to
maybe a much much more careful version
of it in the future
and i think there's in some sense the
question you know does it all need to
happen
in one paper uh maybe it's okay to first
put out a paper where
it captures most of the intuition and it
shows sign alive that if you capture the
intuition
you can really get something and maybe
there's another stage where you know
another paper or two get written that
really carefully go in and say okay well
actually if you do it this way
you you can get even more signal and you
can prove this and this about it
and i think it's often different people
who like to do those
two types of work and i think that's a
big part of the dynamic
and in fact i think that's that's great
i feel like that's where
you know new work gets generated i guess
right yeah yeah so i guess like one
tricky thing about reinforcement
learning is that
not everything that makes intuitive
sense
actually works right so like one
specific
instance of this is uh is of course this
double sampling issue that
that martha was mentioning as well in
this dominar issue
just write down this valid error you
just want to minimize it you just
replace all the expectations by samples
and then a lot of people would expect
that to work right but of course it
doesn't work
and you need to introduce like further
tricks like this saddle point
formulations
uh or or various other tricks
uh which i guess like leads me to the
like a variant of my question that uh
that i was trying to ask before
is that uh do we think that everything
can be reduced
to convex optimization and gradient
descent in reinforcement learning or
or are we gonna need some more tools or
are we gonna need some more
theoretically motivated ideas for things
to work better
um i'm sure other people have an answer
to this question i'm kind of
wondering if maybe maybe we are
so what's the one thing that i think we
probably will need to do we'll need to
understand with sort of the dynamics of
our learning systems
but i wonder if that's going to have to
be restricted to convex
convex losses and exactly using gradient
descent we could imagine analyzing other
types of updates that are not strictly
gradient descent updates but that we
could characterize in some way that
converge to good places
and are stable and so on so i'm kind of
looking forward to a time where we
can look beyond just here's my objective
here's a gradient and think about what
are other ways i could
move towards a good solution but taking
say a different path
that isn't obviously a gradient path
i mean argue with the gradient
correction methods are actually exactly
this because they aren't gradient
methods
but they are still a reasonable
dynamical system that has good
properties and gets to a good
solution
yes and then you can certainly see these
ideas pop up in a lot of theory papers
but then again
i guess my issue is that somehow this
doesn't seem to
uh go through to do the more empirical
deep reality first
and i guess i i'm just back to this uh
today's question is okay how can we
publicize these results better
how can we tell more people about double
sampling how can we
tell you more people about this gradient
corrections and
and help people be educated better
that's a good question yeah i i i
someone else probably wants to say
something but i
kind of like what amir masood said here
do you mind if i repeat out loud what
amir masood wrote because i'm not sure
if everyone can see it when it says to
all panelists
yeah maybe you should speak up no i mean
go ahead
okay so uh so i guess it's kind of like
a
maybe cynical viewpoint uh
if we start from say basically well the
way i see rl is mostly
started from mdp knowing the model and
then we gradually approximate things and
in mdp literature
basically we can categorize the number
of methods in
few categories i mean value iteration
policy iteration can argue that both of
them are variation of modified pulse
iteration
maybe policy gradient which is a
softened policy iteration
and linear programming and then
many other methods are kind of various
approximation of it
so sometimes i wonder uh have been
missed any kind of big class of methods
that are very different from any of them
which might exist i mean in theory and
work very well
of course i mean it's difficult to
answer because if we knew it it wouldn't
be missed
uh but when i go back to kind of the
theory of or
why we have these value traditions or
something like value iteration
it somehow seems a bit not arbitrary but
just
one solution that seems that
say maybe belmont out about it and
sounds reasonable because he knew
something about i don't know fixed point
iteration of operators and then he
applied it and
everything worked uh is there anything
that we need to know
or we can discover that or you feel that
might be there but we don't know
that's i totally agree i i even think we
can go
further by saying the market decision
process is good for amazon
for reinforcement learning
can you say that again sorry you're
cutting out a bit
i i'm i'm saying that we can't even go
further on
asking if markup decision processes is a
good formalism for reinforcement
learning
well have we managed to solve the markov
decision processes
is that talk theory no but uh
something else i agree with the point of
view of amir
uh but uh yeah most of the finger
variation of
police duration by iteration or linear
programming
some parts of dynamic programming were
not studied that much like linear
programming was not
considered from a practical dew point
for a while
while it's a nice theoretical work and
it has been
recently uh some more revived by the
dies framework
but leon could talk about this and
it can create a new body of literature i
think really
but maybe uh having something else then
mp or pi or vi
will require having a different
formalism and
the markup decision processes and there
are some alternatives
you have inference as control control
has a probabilistic inference you have
the mineral mdps
the one from photograph and a few other
things
but yeah it's a hard question but i
think that's
still so much to do with mdps too
and also regarding the practical
empirical
uh thing as a theoretical thing i think
it's a go on back stuff because
i think many i don't know how many but
um there are deep learning
different environment learning
algorithms that have been produced by
people coming from
differing and not necessarily with a
big background on reinforcement learning
or on its theory
but we came with some ideas that
maybe made no sense from a reinforcement
learning point of view at the first
sight
and then thinking about it it was you
need a very clever thing
and you can say things theoretically so
i really think it's a go and back
stuff that is important
and it's not specific to learning to do
math and physics it's the same story
and the last thing about the unification
of theory
uh it's not that's the same as you said
before
uh i mean uh uh politics
is not the same as uh regular value
iteration
and so on so if we call all these
different approaches the same name maybe
we
could lose something and by trying to
ground everything in the theory
we might miss some opportunity to to do
better things to
give new ideas for the story and so on
if i can jump in on this also um
i think there is an opportunity to to
what do you say educate
or bring new algorithms to the table
through open source software
uh and it's probably easier to do than
it used to be right and
actually in fact a lot of the tools that
people end up using are
based on what is my neighbor using and
you know what is the
open source package that i can the most
easily download and
what programming language do i feel
comfortable with um
i wonder if there's an opportunity here
to say you know hey some of these
algorithms actually fairly
easy to implement let's add them to open
source packages
for example you know why not dopamine
[Music]
and maybe if they aren't then that's a
sign that something else needs to happen
in terms of how do you actually get this
to be implemented
yes that's right that's a great point
like usually when this final year
project in my reinforcement learning
course
i see many of the same lines of code
popping up from
certain code bases
so i very much agree that the ideas that
end up winning are the ones that are
easily accessible
in in open source software i mean i
think the case was made for uct a long
time ago right
at uct ucds have prevailed as a search
algorithm for many of these domains
because it was
both easily implemented and actually
robust to implementation errors
uh so maybe maybe the same applies to
our algorithms
right right right so stop proving
theorems and start
coding
even sorry interrupted
maybe not going that far i think it's
interesting to look at the open source
code when it's available because you
have some very efficient
algorithm uh that are stored in the
paper
away and it's not the reason for why
the algorithm work and maybe it's
i'm not saying that it's fooling me but
uh maybe
it's easier to to sell some uh fancy
theory what's the core reason for
the algorithm to work is different and
so seeing reading the cut gonna be
helpful it would be better to have it in
the paper but
some very smart things are not in the
paper or not done in the code
so i i think even for steration uh
looking at the code is useful
yes yes i agree so i think nevada wanted
to say something i was going to say the
exact same thing as matthew like
it's not really like the vanilla version
of the algorithm that makes it work it's
all the tricks in the code
so yeah it's a cool other kind of words
is that true of your algorithm too
uh well we only um implemented things on
like simple uh cases like
tabular and linear and actually
everything is implemented exactly
except for like uh api in the linear
case we had to kind of approximate
the uh boltzmann temperature
but like if we implemented it with
neural networks i imagine maybe we would
need like
a bunch more tricks to make it work
this is an interesting um i wonder if
this is there could be several reasons
one is that um optimization is not done
well enough
with neural networks another is that uh
it could be that
are we looking at the right objective
function
if you look at papers for example the
2009
td2 to paper there are several options
and the more
objective functions this is uh which one
is the right one i think um it's not
complete to me
um i just want to i'm curious what
people think about
the right objective function for real is
for another function for examination not
possibly because the gradient is
relatively
clear
okay so lee hong you're saying you're
not sure what the right objective is
because there's so many out there or
because
the like we don't know how we should
trade our function approximation
resources or or what
maybe say more yes yeah
i think i'm sort of getting what li hong
is getting uh like
there are like so many out there we
don't know you know if optimizing one is
better than the other and it would be
nice to understand like you know
if i want to do like policy evaluation
with this and this function class
what is the the objective for me to
optimize as you were saying
right that you know if you have a linear
function class then of course you should
be optimizing the projected down here
if i have something else then then
what the hell do i do where and how do i
start am i just going to take the usual
dq and objective and optimize that
or can i do something more clever
i agree and we can even frame this as
um if you look at your public learning
for proper classification
you don't optimize for the accuracy
directly because
there's very good reason for not doing
this and you optimize for
proxy and in reinforcement learning even
if you know the good
objective function that is maximizing
the value we're not really using
that much proxies but it's more
difficult so what would be the
hinge loss or the cross-country loss of
reinforcement learning
i think it's an interesting direction of
research
yes this is this is one of my other
hobby horses as well it's like
well why the bellman error and why the
squared bomb on
error so we know that of course the
optimal solution the bomb on error is
zero
and of course you know if you square it
it's still zero
but why are we using this particular
distance metric
uh and why not something completely
different
does anybody have like a better
candidate for this
yeah in a sense these objectives are not
arbitrary um they're consistent in the
sense that if you solve
you make them completely zero you get
the optimal
policy or solution but when some
optimality it
has is unavoidable then are these still
good candidates for proxies
that's the i think that's the question
yes sure i mean you can count with other
objective functions that are going to be
you know zero when you have the optimal
policy just the same
the question is how would we answer this
question like how would we know that we
have the right objective function or how
can we tell
the world here's the objective function
we should use so li hang are you
imagining that
we should have an answer to this
question or that we should be doing way
more experiment
across settings what works well or the
theory should tell us you know this is
the right choice
yeah i suppose that just because we
managed to show upper bounds
for a certain loss function doesn't mean
that that is the ultimate answer
maybe that's something let me add
something to this actually because i
um i was having a conversation with a
good colleague of mine here at mcgill
who was in mathematics and we were
talking about deep reinforcement
learning and he was
very surprised that we were finding
solutions
that while we start from the bellman
equation
we end up with a solution that does not
actually satisfy an equation
right because your function
approximation errors and so it means you
have
everywhere your equation is not being
satisfied
and um i mean in practice we actually
see this in the sense that when we use
td methods we find very different
solution concepts and when we use
residual integrated methods
and i think that's why tdd methods tend
to work better that they're doing
something different they're trading up
these things differently but to me
that's also saying there's we have these
massive blinders if we
start from the bellman equation and
pretend we're solving it because we're
actually not solving it we're doing
something completely different
and so the zero order case is not the
right one to look at at all
if that makes sense yes yes yes it makes
perfect sense like if you look at the
dqn objective
or if you or if you look at q learning
it's usually not even sure if it has a
fixed point right you need
to make some very very strong
assumptions and there are no encounter
examples in which it doesn't have
anything
so we probably need some better
formulations for this
so lee hong do you think that the these
approximations to the bellman era are
not the right objective function
um i'm not sure let's move that's why i
asked
i feel like it's sort of we if there's a
hopeful thing right now or we don't know
the answer to this question yet but i
feel like we're well poised now to start
answering the question like all these
recent developments i think are going to
help us both test things empirically to
sort of guide like what looks like it's
the most promising empirically
and then maybe i mean there's a lot of
nice theory that's happening right now
none seems to be just producing a bunch
of different things
maybe we'll see some theory telling us
too maybe but i guess what i'm saying is
maybe we will get an answer to this
question but it's just a tad too early
right
so in the end the day we um agree that
uh the aria is about maximizing reward
then perhaps reward maximization is the
real objective that we really care about
then i think the now the missing link is
the
connecting value function error to
reward maximization objective
we'll have some down there but the
bounds are perhaps a little bit too
loose to be
removable i mean to me
so i think i i totally agree with this
uh maybe potentially very loose link
between velma equation and the optimal
uh like optimal policy or the correct
value function right
but but i think to me personally that
the reason you spell my equation
is mainly for the off policy or even the
fully offline batch setting
where you just don't have too much more
choice
well where in the online setting you can
afford to do
much more and do things that are uh
very different and in the offline
setting and it is very nice that mars i
mentioned the double sampling difficulty
and and uh and uh i'll just say some
quick technical things like instead of
the squared belmonaire
and in recent years i've found
personally like being very much
attracted by
uh what i've been calling like average
bombing error uh where you just
average all the bellman errors across
different state actions like
together but using different weighting
functions right so that's i think a very
nice other way to resolve the double
sampling difficulty because when you
take the marginal expectation over a
whole distribution
your double sampling difficulty like
automatically goes away but i agree like
it still takes
i mean we're mainly investigating this
approach
like pretty much in early stage and we
still need time and
empirical evidence to tell us whether
this is truly
uh promising or not
i think lehon you bring up a really good
point that whenever we do value
estimation we're usually imagining it's
in service to control and we're not
somehow
directly optimizing for the control
performance when we do value estimation
but i will say that some cases people
actually just want to do value
estimation
very small number of cases it is
actually possible you might want to
estimate values and then there we might
actually want to understand what's the
best objective for this easier question
which is how accurate can my values be
and then maybe we shouldn't even be
learning values if we're doing control i
don't know
all right one other thing out there in
terms of objective which is um
minimizing the amount of human
interaction required to completion
so let's say if you train alpha go zero
no human interaction required
you just run it and you're done but for
many practical
problems maybe the reward has to come
from a person
and they can give different kinds of
rewards and how much attention they have
to pay to the whole thing
and you finish to start thinking about
very very different problems at that
point so i think about okay
what if i tried to model the human how
accurately do i need to model the
human's feedback mechanism to be able to
keep learning
and when do i need to go back to human
and so it's a different kind of sample
complexity
where you only count human interaction
time and not
simulator time
right and you have some constraints on
the training procedure itself
rather than on the final policy that you
wanna output
you don't wanna have tragic disasters
uh during the training procedure
no disaster so safety or it could just
be efficiency it could just be
you want something trained you want it
trained and
you want to spend minimal time on it as
as the human designer
or somebody you hire to spend time with
it but you consider
you consider samples free essentially
which i think is very uncommon right now
but you can in principle consider
samples free as long as there's no human
involved
that setting is quite interesting too
right and it feels to me that it's very
difficult to start from a dynamic
programming perspective and design an
algorithm that respects these kind of
constraints
yeah so maybe i just add something about
consistent discussion about the bell
menu or i guess
i guess that's true like it is upper
bound of what we want so
it's a surrogate uh kind of objective
which may not necessarily be the best
thing but i think we can
divide some kind of the question to two
parts one is that
uh whether there are other objective
surrogate objectives that are easy to
compute other than
some norm of belmont residual and then
the other is that if we restrict
ourselves to beyond a residual
or that some norm of burner is a job but
norm is the right one
and usually we use some form of l2 with
respect to some measure
uh and even if we restrict to that case
i guess it is not
obvious what measure it should be
especially if you want to
think about the case of control because
it doesn't necessarily mean that if we
make some error
in this region of state space uh in the
future next
after a few iterations like policy
improvement we are still
what would be the effect of that and i
think we have this kind of error
propagation results that show
how these errors propagate i think the
problem with
most of them is that it is difficult to
compute them
so we can't know a priory what is the
right
norm essentially or no right mission
yes right there are so many different
ways in reinforcement learning when we
talk about how to acquire
samples and well there's a lot of work
empirical work that uses
uh replay buffers whereas it's very rare
to see theoretical studies considering
this
most of the theories about like
minimizing sample complexity or regrets
or these kind of notions but this is
this is not what
happens in the most spectacular
applications of deep area right there
you always have some kind of a simulator
that they can reset a bunch of times
so maybe maybe you should allocate some
effort in trying to understand
the hardness of learning with these
oracles as well
and kind of interesting thing is that
like peter's talk like that w function
is essentially changing that measure and
it empirically performed very well so
why does it
and i think kind of trying to find what
is the ideal
or why ideal might be what peter found
that would be interesting i think
so gerge going back to your point are
you saying we should write down
a white paper things that deep our
practitioners are doing that theorists
are not looking at
yes sure yeah i guess that would be a
good idea to have like a list on both
ends right
yeah i guess that that was actually
going to be my
next and maybe final question is like
what are these
critics that are being used in deep rl
that are really not looked at by
practitioners so like yeah
the replay buffer is one of these
another thing
uh that really puzzles me is uh is
this truncation idea in ppo this
proximal policy optimization algorithm
there the entropy organization part is i
would say
sort of well understood by now uh but
the trunnication bit is not so much
so i'm just i'm just curious about like
what are your favorite hacks that
uh that you would want to see understood
anybody feeling strongly about sure well
we've been pushing pretty hard last year
on combining unsupervised learning and
reinforcement learning
and i think you know what does it mean
to combine them in in the right way
have them you know benefit from each
other rather than
you know interfere uh kind of generally
multitask interference kind of problems
could occur
so i think it's a lot of open questions
there
yes yes that's right well i suppose like
a lot of these i mean there are two
categories
here right one where you don't even know
like what is the precise problem
formulation or what what is even the
the question to ask right
or another one where well there is like
sort of a precisely formulated question
but like nobody
ever really looked at that and i guess
maybe we have
more of the first type in reinforcement
learning that's why
that's my feeling somehow
there's a lot of empirical things that
we don't understand that while in rl
um the use of the experience we play
buffer i think can use a lot of thought
but i suppose some of the offline
batch rl stuff is getting us some
insights some into
somewhat into the use of the experience
replay buffer
i don't have a great answer for you
gergei because i don't know actually
that are used
that seem to be important sometimes i
have a i assume that tricks that were
added were added
and they may or may not have been
important and so i suppose as time
passes the tricks that were important
trickle out as because they stay in the
code but i don't know which of the
tricks were actually useful and which of
the tricks just happened to be there
yeah yeah yeah i'm puzzled by the same
things as well
i think a big one i don't know if it
deserves study but it's distributed
training
uh i mean if you look at what most
of these big projects are using right
there's there's some amount of
distributed training and there's some
amount
of maybe caching going on right where
now it matters how fresh your policies
are that you're collecting data with and
what what is the impact of that on your
um you know i i was reading a paper
recently that was pointing out that for
example when you do prioritize replay
um if you insert a new data point
into the buffer and you didn't compute
you sort of so
make sure that you train it right away
by saying the priority to maximum
that actually hurts performance quite a
bit so sure like so now you have to
compute it ahead of time
in theory it seems like a trivial
operation to just say do the right thing
but the practical reality is now if you
try to implement this one way or the
other
it complicates things quite a bit so
but at the same time there might be
algorithmic solutions that
that just require a little bit deeper
thought to say you know this is how you
would
one thing we don't do very well i think
in rl is often to consider the runtime
cost
of some of these algorithms right and
and you know
rich would love to hear their cert but
the reality is most of the algorithms
that are getting used today are linear
time algorithm or sort of
constant time per sample uh so
yeah so you must be satisfied with that
but i guess the problem is
i have one for you also um this is not
rl specific per se but
when people do ensembles they
they just randomly initialize the
network and that's it
whereas the theory of ensembling says
that you should
subsample you know different subsets and
there's a big i mean in practice nobody
does a sampling thing or
it doesn't matter and somehow you know i
think that's an example of a big gap
between theory and practice
that's very precise yeah yeah yeah and i
guess like more generally this belongs
to this question of
uncertainty quantification which is
apparently
widely believed to be the key to do
efficient exploration in reinforced and
learning
so of course if you want to do it right
then you want to sample the weights from
a particular distribution you're going
to subsample
and then you want to make sure that
you're sampling from the right
posteriors and everything
yeah that was there was a bit of a
discussion about that yesterday as well
yeah and this is a very exciting segue
to
actually say that uh there will be a
discussion about uncertainty again
on friday uh for now we should possibly
wrap up since it's quarter past
the three o'clock oh yes um
georgie maybe i'll let you say the final
words in the discussion and then i'll
wrap up for the session itself oh no i i
really
just want to thank everybody for showing
up and discussing so intensely this is
interesting uh so let's uh let's
continue
this and i'm gonna start writing on my
my
book of open problems for theorists and
practitioners
so yeah let's stay in touch regarding
that and now i guess it's time to head
into this gather town
thingy i suppose there should be a link
posted to that
uh somewhere in the chat so yeah see you
there thank you everybody
thank you thanks to all the speakers
today as well thank you gerges for
hosting the discussion and
see you again uh get it done tomorrow
thanks for agreeing to write two books
gargay
thank you goodbye
thank you bye thanks everyone thank you
bye